people always say that well once you
become a VP or once you become the CEO
it's easy to be your authentic self and
I actually don't think that's true
because in 2016 I stood up in front of
task rabbit in July and talked about
what it's like to be black and I I was
so scared I was the CEO of company I had
just become the CEO I could get up and
say anything I wanted but I was so
scared about what people would think
what would they think about well she's
going to talk about her experience
because we're seeing all these police
officers kill black men but it was
important to me to get up in front of
our company meeting and not have a
regular meeting but to let them know who
I am how I'm feeling and the pain that I
was going through at the time and so I
think digging deep and being willing to
be vulnerable those are the moments
where it's actually really good to be
yourself because what happened after
that was these this follow-up
conversation from so many people in the
company about what it meant to be from
wherever they were from and so being
vulnerable had really helped me build
deep connections so when we went through
the hard stuff at tasken which we and
every every did every company will like
I had a team with me and they knew me
and they understood me and they were
much more committed to the vision and
the strategy and the purpose of what we
were trying to do